台灣股市今天看起來要崩盤了
禮拜五 應該說禮拜六早上
美股收盤
不是台灣股市要漲個3 400點嗎
怎麼今天崩了
台股量能急凍 崩盤前兆
擔憂AI毀滅人類
你不要以為開玩笑
今天跌真的是因為這個原因
我再講一次
今天所有跌
如果講跌不是這個原因的
那絕對是不入流的分析師
我沒有針對誰 一定不認真
現在是擔憂AI毀滅人類
被迫放緩研究
這是今天台灣股市跌的主因 真的嗎
第三個 沙烏地東西
兩邊的油管都被封鎖了
不論是紅海的 荷姆茲海峽的
那都被封鎖了 都運不出去了
通膨沒救了嗎
這三大問題怎麼辦
今天我一次講個清楚
投資朋友 我是摩爾投顧的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
也是唯一140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
你不認識哲哲 你一定是股市菜鳥
來 我們先來講一件事
今天擔憂AI毀滅人類
就是這個新聞 來
來看一下這個新聞
AI三強有沒有
阿莫戴 這個啦
就是Anthropic這個
Claude這個創辦人
這是奧特曼有沒有看到
就是ChatGPT的
還有馬斯克
三個人覺得怎麼樣 呼籲
放緩AI的效能推進速度
大家覺得擔心 慘了啦
你今天問AI最新消息要問我
不要看其他人
我不是要攻擊別人 我講事實
因為我一切的一切預告在前面
等一下你就知道 來
AI三巨頭說
慘了啦 要放緩啦
趕快 因為AI太恐怖了
裡面的研究員逃出來的說
有10%
不要說10% 1%都恐怖了
10% AI可以像天網一樣
像魔鬼終結者那種一樣
可以控制全世界的網路
然後怎麼樣
然後毀滅全人類
他說至少10%
大家聽了恐怖啦
然後開始有人講
AI三巨頭呼籲一下
放緩AI效能推進速度
那大家擔心什麼
第一個 真的會毀滅人類嗎
第二個 好啦 你要放緩AI的研發
是不是台灣的台積電資本支出減少了
是不是就不買晶片了
我給你結論
錯 大錯特錯
那我跟你講
今天這一段節目
你也不要看其他分析師了
因為哪個分析師 大家留言
哪個分析師告訴你
AI發展會很快的
我直接畫那張圖
我直接跟你講 我常常畫
來 看一看就知道我跟別人的差別
我說AI發展不是這樣子
我說AI發展是近乎90度
這是時間軸 這個還太緩了
來 所有的工程師
為什麼那麼多工程師喜歡看我的東西
我怎麼畫那麼醜 再來一次
老人家是不是 手變抖了
這樣是不是歧視老人家
近乎90度的發展
有沒有 我說近乎90度的發展
這什麼意思 很簡單嗎
這種東西是怎麼樣
就是橫軸是T 時間
這是發展的一個速度
知道嗎 發展的速度
Y軸 你聽得懂就好
橫軸是T 這是什麼意思
一個時間內
因為我當初沒有解釋T
是因為我相信你們都懂
我後來想一想你們可能不懂
這跟我原本的講法是一致的
本來隔很長的時間慢慢發展
我說馬上很短時間內一直發展
當然是要這種90度
才會馬上天網
才會變成毀滅人類
你告訴我哪個分析師
有跟你講這個東西
所以我說3年10萬點有沒有錯
沒有錯
現在他們講這些東西
還是3年10萬點
我先問你一件事情
我只要問你兩個東西你就知道
謠言不攻自破 來
這個只能代表
是代表AI會毀滅人類嗎
不一定
他們三個擔心這件事代表什麼意思
是不是發展真的很快
圈圈 沒錯吧 再講一次
他們三個人 三大巨頭
馬斯克至少聽過吧
ChatGPT的創辦人
ChatGPT你知道吧
你不知道創辦人是誰吧
ChatGPT創辦人
Anthropic的創辦人
寫程式的工程師
都一定會用Anthropic
你現在寫程式沒在用Anthropic
Claude
我跟你講你早就被淘汰了
所有的資工系 資工所的
一定知道我在講什麼
這三大巨頭 兩個創辦人
最有名的創辦人
還有特斯拉創辦人馬斯克
說AI要緩慢
AI進展太快了 要緩慢 要監控他
這代表什麼意思
是代表AI真的毀滅人類了嗎
有這個風險對不對
是AI會毀滅人類嗎
是AI真的進步太快嗎 進展太快嗎
叮叮 沒錯吧
你們要改變人生啊
我有沒有說10年內
你們會解決很多癌症
你們自己不相信我
哪個分析師有畫這張圖
你告訴我嘛
說這個90度這樣垂直進展
你告訴我是不是
哲哲早就預告在前面
那我再問你一個邏輯就知道了
來聽我的邏輯就對了
我請問大家一件事
我就請問你
一堆人之前講AI泡沫
不能變現
現在你們又嫌進步太快了
你在說什麼東西啊
從頭到尾就是進步很快
所以至少AI沒有泡沫嘛
至少AI很容易變現嘛
他都可以毀滅人類了
還有什麼做不到的
你要搞清楚啊
為什麼可以毀滅人類
因為他們變成一群組織
他有自主意識了
你聽得懂嗎
應該不能說自主意識
應該是說AGI的感覺
他可以從無到有去學習
我那時候講AGI
我是不是說改變人類的社會出來了
我有沒有講 你們在底下留言
我有沒有這些預告
我說AI進步很快 獨家預告
所以至少把那以前喊做空的
或者是說AI可能會變現
可能變現不足的人
通通被打巴掌
他們講的邏輯完全錯誤啦 是不是
現在已經AI毀滅人類
這不是不可能
因為我已經說
我那時候是不是說AGI很恐怖
我是因為AGI出來的時候
我說3年10萬點
我現在照樣不改變
我講的3年10萬點的說法
OK嗎 記清楚喔
好不好 記清楚喔
來 你看一下
你看一下我那時候講的
2023年
請你看一下2023年
2023年3月24號
有沒有看到 2023年3月24號
ChatGPT一開始發明的時候
看一下喔 三年前
助理 查一下ChatGPT
用維基百科告訴他們
2023年3月24號
我說他指數型的成長 來
你看一下 看一下
需要給你們定義指數型嗎
我不是要上數學課的 好不好
OK嗎
不要上數學課了 這樣你們很累啦
剛才那近乎90度
也是指數型的成長 來
我給你看一下
你看一下你會覺得我是變態
3年前的預告喔
3年後你再看我這次預告 10萬點喔
來 先看一下
氣死了 等我一下喔
不見了 來
大家等我一下 氣死了
給你們看那個點數又壞掉
提醒助理
麻煩助理以後那個大盤走勢圖
要幫我打開來
等我一下
我給你看2023年3月24號
助理你看有沒有時間
直接幫我做張圖比較快
我現在什麼事都用AI
我很多員工處理不了事
來問我的時候
我是先唸他們一次
我說你是不會用AI喔
先問AI 不行再由我來處理
基本上問完AI你還要我來處理
代表你也不會用AI
還要再被我唸第二次
真的啊
除非是人的事情
人的事情問AI也可以處理喔
真的喔 好不好
這個是跟大家講 來
哲哲馬上來
看一下2023年3月24號
助理去查一下維基百科
ChatGPT什麼時候出現的
夭壽 它一直給我不見
哭哭
來 先給你們看一下
先看一下你們的那個
大家留言
看一下喔 我先看一下
等一下喔
來 看一下 大家看留言
哲哲是變態
哲哲預告在前面
還沒 還沒 還沒
按讚了
是不是跌都不打領帶
沒有啦 沒有啦
這一兩天而已啦 好不好
來 哲哲是變態
我喜歡你講這句話
來 真的預告在前面
來 按讚
沒打領帶
助理封鎖酸民
不懂就問AI
有沒有其他人的 看一下
有 說哲哲都預告在前面
就算人類毀滅
AI還是自己會發展下去
沒有 他們還是需要電
只是如果有機器人的話
他可以自己產電 自己產水啦 好不好
來 我們來看一下
天啊 他一直不給 我瘋了
大盤的走勢圖不給我
我第一次好絕望
用第三次了
助理給我走勢圖 快點
呼叫助理趕快來
ChatGPT 2022年的11月30號
那時候還沒那麼有名 對啦
你說2022年
沒關係 給你看一下
3年多的時間
是11月30號推出
我怎麼印象中
為什麼我印象中2 3月才開始紅
好不好 我印象中2 3月才紅
好像一開始台灣人
對 好像中文版
是3月才開始紅 好不好
助理幫我查一下是不是中文版
好啦 我不管啦
我印象中是2023年我們常常用
先看一下我這個重播
你們看一下就知道很恐怖
那時候台灣股市大概17000而已
你看一下 來
看一下 2023年3月24號
有沒有看到
2023年3月24號有沒有看到
預告下週噴萬六 有沒有看到
誇不誇張
所以那時候15000 這麼低喔
那時候15000 看一下喔
在2023年的時候
台灣股市15000
到現在漲3倍
如果到時候3年後再漲3倍
是12萬點喔
不是不可能喔
來看一下我的預告 來看一下
直播要關 來看一下
看一下那個時候
標題叫做
預告直接噴萬六 扯不扯
看一下喔
3 2 1
拜託你
我都說了有機會17000以上了
有機會17000
你看那時候16000
為什麼我們行情高 而且AI的那個
AI的成長是指數型的成長
一般是線性型的這樣成長
他指數型是這樣子 90度成長
90度成長有沒有看到
拐點快到了有沒有看到
所以不論對或錯
你們知道什麼叫拐點嗎
就是一個轉折點到了
這個AGI就是拐點
你如果知道什麼是拐點
什麼是我3年前預告
你就覺得很恐怖
我再看一下
我3年前講90度的成長
看一下 我是預言家
我不要每天什麼小鼻子小眼睛
什麼國巨今天拉尾盤 偷拉
哲哲不缺錢 真的很無聊你知道
講一講我都起雞皮疙瘩了
再看一次
3年前的時候預告下週噴萬六
現在人家在討論毀滅人類了啦
你看一下
拜託你
我都說了有機會17000以上了
為什麼我們行情高 而且AI的那個
AI的成長是指數型的成長
一般是線性型的這樣成長
他指數型是這樣子 90度成長
90度成長有沒有看到
就是這樣子有沒有看到 我還這樣畫
現在變成90度成長
拐點出現就好了
拐點快到了 拐點快到
所以不論對或錯
拐點快到了 我有說AGI很恐怖
我有沒有說AGI改變
就變3年10萬點了
什麼叫AGI 通用人工智慧
你以前是大數據法則
要舊資料去查
沒有 你現在是可以無中生有
去了解所有的規則
你可以成為3D設計師
以前是要很多軟體 沒有
龍蝦也是要慢慢下指令
沒有 他現在就可以
他有自主意識
他可以完全幫你下指令
用得更好
你可以叫他剪片
你可以叫他當設計師
可以當你的小秘書 助理
通通可以
這叫AGI
你現在看到的版本
還不是最先進的版本
我有沒有講
3年前預告耶
3年後你會看到台股10萬點
毀滅人類 你想太多了
記不記得奧德賽的導演叫什麼名字
前一個電影叫什麼
原子彈叫什麼
沒關係
發明核子彈的時候
廣島 長崎丟兩顆核子彈
大家不是說人類也要毀滅嗎
還是活得好好的
如果你是那種
哲哲怎麼辦
過馬路會不會被撞死的人
不要投資
每天擔心完擔心不了
我再講一次
這件事只是代表
AI是如我所料的90度的成長
那是代表一定會毀滅人類嗎
沒有就不要管那麼多
就算毀滅
一起死 關你什麼事
電影看太多了
有可能 那很好啊 謝謝他們
還有另外一個可以講
Anthropic ChatGPT
最厲害的這幾個
跟你講說AI要管制
AI要管制就不用AI喔
還是用AI來管制他
你聽得懂我的意思嗎
要研發AI
研發監督的AI也要時間
研發監督的AI要不要時間
是訓練不要那麼厲害
我推論還是要
所以你知不知道現在最厲害的
助理我有找資料給你
我最近看很多資料
他現在開始丟出API了
什麼叫丟出API
工程師就知道我在講什麼
串接程式了
你現在看那個什麼
那個澳洲漢堡店
有那個AI的語音
那個還算很遜
你現在可以用ChatGPT的語音
跟他講話
我不是說跟他講話很自然
還會咳嗽
你可以用他的程式
串接你要的程式
寫成你要的程式
然後可以更加
我針對不同企業
我可以幫你規劃客服
他開放API了 為什麼
以後你用一次 他跟你收錢
那你也可以
那個串接API是免費的
那你可不可以從這裡面發展
你不要去往最先進的程式發展
你現在程式已經夠厲害了
你現在程式就可以讓幾百萬人失業
我沒跟你開玩笑
現在程式好好研發的好
就可以讓幾百萬人失業了
從頭到尾我就是預言家嘛
3年前耶
導播你有沒有覺得很誇張
我講一講都起雞皮疙瘩
超誇張的
3年前 我跟你講
3年後我告訴你10萬點
我跟你講 我要當預言家
我不要小鼻子小眼睛
那個 不好意思
我國巨 環球晶拉尾盤
環球晶為什麼沒有1000塊
那又怎麼樣
你可不可以等一年後再跟我說
那時候欣興一堆人罵我70塊
一年後1000塊
我喜歡當預言家 我跟你說真的
哲哲不缺錢
我覺得錢來說
我覺得不如讓你們賺錢比較實在
你懂嗎 看一下
是不是 來
看一下有沒有覺得 邏輯很強
去看一下3年前告訴大家
3年前
2023的哲哲
絕對是經典中的經典
我說90度成長
什麼叫90度成長
90度成長就是短時間內
你們可能不相信
就是現在已經討論在毀滅人類
就是可能一年內
AI會群組起來
然後會自己建立自己的AI
因為他們知道用機器人產的
你會覺得AI只是在一般的網路而已
他如果會建立到機器人
機器人有AI頭腦那不得了
他自己可以生產機器人 對啊
90度有沒有看到
奧本海默是不是
對啊 那時候
還不是活著 是不是
哲哲談的是大海 不是漱口杯
對 我想講這句話
但我會怕你們覺得好像有政治傾向
我上次傳竹北市長選舉給AI 超厲害
我聽不懂 來
這個 2023年的哲哲
如果大家 有些人覺得不厲害
那真的是你看到的世界
跟我看到的世界不一樣 好不好
來 今天要按讚喔
不按讚 我就
你看 又要每次威脅
你看 這就是人性
所以為什麼股票
有些賺錢的就是那些人
習慣不好很難賺錢
投資朋友
你一定要記得我的邏輯 好不好
OK嗎
哲哲還要買嗎
有信心 要有信心
我再講一件事
現在 今天台灣股市所有人下跌
哪個分析師跟你講說什麼東西
CPI 升降息沒有關係喔
而且我預測很準喔
我是不是說CPI數據3.4%以下會漲
後來就漲了
含3.4% 我有講喔
沒錯吧
只是因為現在台股跌了
你覺得我不準
因為禮拜六 禮拜天又出一個新聞
可是禮拜五的確是因為CPI
3.4%以下噴出去
但是3.4%有另外一種說法
因為已經預期了
現在有另外一種說法是升息升定了
那不管嘛 至少3.4%以下漲了嘛
只是現在大家在討論是
AI要毀滅人類 你懂嗎
AI要毀滅人類 來看一下
來啦 AI會自我改進能力有沒有
我說是90度角嘛
AI群體協力駭進
Hugging Face
這個以前就知道了
這些人作弊嘛
為什麼AGI出現才講
這前幾個月就知道的事情
為什麼現在才呼籲
因為大家看到AGI覺得很恐怖
第一個
第二個 真的全公司前幾名啊
不好意思喔
美國人 不好意思
我產生了最多的核子彈啦
然後我們一起不擴散核子彈
我有幾千顆 幾萬顆
你們只有幾百顆
我們一起不要擴散
先拿第一名才說不要擴散
先拿了第一名的AI程式以後
才跟你講說我們不要擴散
那其他人呢
沒有關係啊 你們停止研發
我要趕上來啊
讀書時代 你是不是最討厭那種
我都沒有讀書啦
不好意思 我都第一名啦
我跟你講啦
我們不要認真讀書
身體健康最重要啦
回到家他還在熬夜啦
你覺得這些人不會發展嗎
騙人 有沒有遇過那種
我沒讀書啦
我跟你講
我考試好爛喔 沒準備啦
考第一名
你還真的相信他喔
小時候我還真的相信耶
後來都不相信人家講的話
小時候我很容易被他騙 胡扯啦
看到所有成功人士
每個都比大家認真努力
你不要聽那些胡扯啦
那個小計謀而已啦
問題是怎樣
以前會真的被騙
成人的世界會被騙嗎
我們要放緩AI
叫你們放緩AI 我自己研發啦
好啦 我們前三名放緩啦
四五六名會理他嗎
等到我100分的時候
99分的時候我再放緩可不可以
懂我在說什麼嗎
你為什麼不懂AI
你看我的作圖
為什麼都是比人家漂亮
是不是
那他說要踩煞車
內部要評估人員
那是不是要設計AI
民主國家共同安全標準
那中國大陸怎麼辦 是不是
中國大陸會理他嗎
莫斯科會理他嗎
歐盟會理他嗎
雲端大咖放慢基建腳步 為什麼會放慢
大家覺得這個邏輯
我是前端研發
我不讓他AI馬上研發AI
我不讓AI去生成一群AI
但是我會怎麼樣 我會先準備好
我還是要怎麼樣 我還是要水電
我還是要雲端伺服器的設備
沒錯吧 我還是要基地
怎麼可能你就不投資了
你是AI的投資人
你會知道未來會發生什麼事嗎
你一定先投資好
我再講一次
前幾個月還每個人在討論AI不能變現
現在已經討論AI毀滅人類了
會不會跳太快
從頭到尾AI就進步很快
所以從頭到尾AI是隨時可以變現的
只是大家需要時間
我之前跟我們公司的廠商講
我說你要不要設計
可能再過一兩年
你不設計 我來設計
我說我只要按一鍵
我們所有的業務人員只要按一個鍵
填好時間 填好日期
我說憑我的邏輯我可以生出來
我們現在需要8 9個行政人員
然後有時候業績好的時候
業績好的時候 像上半年很好
我要加班到10點 9點
然後一堆人
我說不必 一個按鍵
說不定他們其他人都可以做很多事了
都可以做別的事了
或者轉其他的職務
我跟他講 我說你再不生這個程式
我自己生
我是很認真跟他講
我覺得現在只要邏輯好
什麼程式都可以生出來
那都可以變現 只是需要時間而已
你以後會發現到
再講一次
你要看到我看到的未來
以後一堆客服人員
我也在此呼籲政府 台灣政府
真的拜託趕快開放FSD
台灣是科技之島 結果不能用自駕車
你不覺得很好笑嗎
可是我講多了 變成攻擊政府
我人微言輕 我沒有要攻擊誰
這個扯遠了
不過我真的希望
AI會有很多變現
你以後看到很多的客服人員
很多的程式設計會出來
他現在不能
我再講一件事
他現在不能開發什麼
不能開發 假設啦 最壞
不能開發最先進 最先進的
那他需不需要從旁邊開發監督AI
需要啊
這個很簡單的邏輯
那他不要訓練這一塊讓他變強
那我推理這一塊可不可以變強
也需要AI 也需要雲端伺服器
訓練跟推理不知道沒關係嘛
還有我訓練這一塊
我最前端的邊界
邊界感要有
我最前端的 就是我到這個層級
假設我現在已經到80級
可能瞬間到100級很快
就像打電動一樣 假設
我80級先不要
我把AI停留在80級
那我可以1到80級
所有可以變現的AI我全部生出來
API全部生出來
我1到80級的AI
所有的 比如說AI客服人員
相關的 我打開來
讓你們串接API
讓你們去想這些程式
我是不是開始收錢了
是不是開始變現了
我可以集中火力在這邊
懂我在說什麼嗎
不懂很正常
連剛才我覺得起雞皮疙瘩都很少人懂
沒關係 曲高和寡
你們只是永遠看到
郭哲榮39000丟1億
你知不知道我怎麼賺1億的
靠頭腦啊 各位
靠頭腦 懂不懂
沒有關係 OK嗎
靠頭腦
你要記得講這件事情好不好
你看3年前
我真的跳太快
3年前講這個90度好不好
哲哲你Threads是不是好了
我好了 就是以這個為主好不好
不要看截圖
有些人會把我的帳號
然後改圖
不要看圖片什麼LINE
我沒有什麼
我的LINE就是這個
要不要加隨便你
以YouTube的說明為主好不好
Threads就是以這個帳號
s178178 OK嗎
你看到圖片有人用截圖
用s178178講話說要加LINE
那是假的
我要不要加LINE隨便你 OK嗎
而且我加完LINE以後 來看一下
你們真的不懂沒關係
要Threads要加LINE沒關係
他叫我加LINE
只有以這個LINE為主
來 看清楚
沒關係 謝謝LINE 來
s178178
現在沒有藍勾勾沒關係
你們只要看到有人叫你加LINE
來 跟所有人講
詐騙集團這個生不出來 好不好
置頂的對話
有盾牌 白勾勾有沒有看到
要有盾牌白勾勾有沒有看到
盾牌 這是白勾勾
NIKE 白勾勾 盾牌
外面是盾牌
這邊 有沒有看到
盾牌加白勾勾
盾牌白勾勾
點照片有寫已認證
這邊名字後面有寫已認證
這邊寫已認證沒有用
要這邊寫已認證
因為我怕他們會改圖
他們有些會改圖
這邊打勾勾沒有用
是在這邊 已認證
這是官方LINE
現在是不是所有分析師
都在學我們摩爾了
我當初就說要做嘛
盾牌 這是盾牌
外面有個盾牌有沒有看到
然後白勾勾
盾牌裡面有個白勾勾
這個沒有的話就是假的
百分之百假的
以我裡面說話
有盾牌白勾勾說的話為主
以有盾牌白勾勾說的話為主
這樣懂嗎 OK嗎
再講一次
以有盾牌白勾勾說的話為主
就這麼簡單
就不會被騙了
哲哲沒那麼多時間好不好
AI可以去毀滅詐騙集團 好不好
上週不是說國巨會漲5%以上
對啊 錯了 是啊
如果你覺得哲哲這樣就錯了
那不好意思
我怎麼知道發生那麼多事情 好不好
沒有辦法 好不好
你這個口氣還好
如果口氣太差就Byebye
覺得我不準 Byebye 好不好
藍盾牌白勾勾
抽漢測 沒錢加碼環球晶
我覺得你們不要去抽籤了 你相信我
我跟你講 抽籤是有錢有閒的人
你不要去賣股票來抽籤
我講個東西好不好
我之前 跟你講個故事就好
抽籤是最無聊的
除非是定存裡面的錢
甚至活存裡面的錢
是銀行裡面的錢
可是我覺得銀行不需要那麼多錢
銀行的錢應該買台灣50
有啦 銀行多少你會留一些錢
是銀行的錢去抽籤
絕對不要賣股票去抽籤
我講個最簡單的例子
我是不是從10萬塊起家
當完兵從10萬塊起家
很快的 沒幾年的時間
我10萬塊就滾到500萬
我很敢滾 那時候很敢衝
比你還敢衝
但是我現在不建議你
我覺得那時候運氣好
500萬以後
我就是開始用抽籤的
收集家裡很多的帳戶
他們不抽 我來抽
你懂我的意思嗎
那時候算過大概有
大概有差不多10%到20%的報酬率
我跟你講 我以前做股票的時候
10% 20%很厲害好不好
一年有10% 20%很厲害
我想說500萬的我就賣一點點
我賺個幾千萬就好
那時候以前沒想過現在會賺那麼多
你知道嗎
那一兩年是我報酬最差的時候
眼睜睜看行情往上噴 什麼意思
你為了要抽籤
你反而錯過很多飆股
你資金會卡住
哲哲 抽只是抽一段時間
沒有 你會繼續抽下去
聽得懂嗎
所以你不要為了賣股票去抽籤
抽什麼漢測 是不是
漢測嘛 這是最傻的事情
可以抽籤
但是你不要為了賣股票去抽籤
你不要籌錢去抽籤 懂不懂
那時候算過
什麼10% 20%的報酬率
可能3%嘛
我用10個人頭戶不就30%嗎
是不是 這個沒問題吧
合法的 幾十年前的事情了
對不起 哲哲看起來年紀很大
但是股市30年了
不要學 這不要學 真的
不是 你要銀行有錢
但是你不要賣股票去抽籤好不好
現在行情跟以前哪個比較好做
現在3萬塊可以滾到500萬嗎
現在行情比以前好做死啦
你看3年前才1萬多
我說3年後就10萬點還不好做
你們真的很幸福 有夠好做
現在AI可以查資料
我們哪有啊
以前研究員寫個報告
就是算是放屁 對不起
你都覺得是香的
現在不必了
研究員寫報告你也不要
你不要一定要看券商寫的報告
不用 你去問AI就可以了
現在資訊很平等 你懂不懂
那我們分析師留著幹嘛
不好意思 我們給你做最後的建議
OK嗎
我是不是越來越
網路上是不是越來越多人講了
以後什麼老師不重要
老師是教你做人而已
教你那個知識不需要
2023的哲哲
絕對是經典中的經典
2020年也是
叫你要買口罩 叫你要打疫苗
叫你1年內要發明疫苗
然後2021年 2022年叫你要打疫苗
我很多經典的東西
還有2024年空手道 有沒有
行情就跌個5 6000點
最低點那一天買進
哲哲哪有
你以為我100多萬只紅一次 好不好
我有閱讀障礙只能看哲哲
因為我也有閱讀障礙
所以我們兩個都講話跳來跳去
哲哲奮鬥史很厲害
本來想要質押去抽籤
質押抽籤
不錯 質押抽籤可以
我覺得質押抽籤可以
這兩個 就是本來想要
質押抽籤沒什麼風險
你們幫我想一下有沒有什麼風險
質押抽籤很棒
我第一次覺得可以借錢的時候
就是這個時候
你懂不懂
反正買了就可以直接賣了
我都不建議你抽籤
我身為公眾人物
我不建議你要去借錢
雖然以前我會用融資 權證
但是因為我是我 你是你
我有100多萬粉絲
我怎麼知道你是哪一種人
一個人因為我受傷 我都不要
可是質押去抽籤的風險
基本上非常小
我不會說0
也不會說百分之百這種事
質押抽籤還有就是質押的費用
還有質押的利息費用對不對 利率
哲哲 我可以應徵我的特助嗎
就是粉絲不一定要當我的特助
我怕我有時候比較機車一點點
真的有時候哲哲
因為哲哲對自己
第一個 我反應比較快
第二個 我對自己的要求也很高
我有時候用我的要求去看別人
我覺得不公平
沒有關係 你們去面試看看好不好
我都很OK
只是丟履歷你們要寫清楚
大部分人丟履歷
有時候就是這樣
就像我跟我朋友 做朋友就好
我也不跟他報股票
一樣的意思
你當我的粉絲就好了
不然你到時候看到哲哲另外一面
也不行 我說真的
好不好 這樣不好
因為有時候我真的對自己機車
其實我對別人
我大概對別人打7折
對女生會打5折
但是我都覺得對他們來說
可能壓力比較大
扯遠了 講股票的事情
不重要 你們想應徵就丟履歷
很好 至少薪水絕對是業界最高
這個我敢打包票 好不好
他剛才說應徵特助 什麼叫特助
我現在缺秘書 好不好
保證100
甚至應該看能力
120 200其實
只要你有能力
你有能力是哲哲認定
不能說沒有經驗你就想要200
絕對100以上好不好
哲哲的秘書
我希望120以上 我真的希望
哲哲都很願意給多的錢
哲哲你騙人
有閱讀障礙怎麼考上政大
閱讀障礙很嚴重
你不覺得我超級容易分心嗎
我真的閱讀障礙
只是輕微閱讀障礙
但是我閱讀障礙滿嚴重的
我輕微 只是說
真的有閱讀障礙
奇怪 我為什麼要跟你解釋
我就說我吃過那個什麼
而且出社會才吃
本來想要裝自己閱讀障礙
發現不用裝了
他講的那個症狀我全部都有
吃了藥才知道
因為有時候不小心給旁邊的人吃
他們都覺得沒有比較專心
可是我變得很專心 扯遠了
可是那都不是我
所以我覺得
我還滿喜歡閱讀障礙的我
來 我們來看一下 看股票
上帝幫你關上門了
就幫你開一扇門
我要是沒有閱讀障礙
我說不定我現在就去當教授
或者當工程師
或怎麼樣 Whatever 是不是
那也沒有什麼好或不好
但是我更喜歡現在 你懂不懂
我現在有這個舞台
然後當預言家有什麼不好
我很開心
你們剛才不知道我那段
講一講我起雞皮疙瘩
你們都覺得還好
那就是代表你們還是沒有
很難過就是你們
還看不懂我看的世界
剛才覺得那段還好嗎 投票一下
這段重播你們覺得沒意義嗎
剛才那段重播就是說
來看一下這一段
真的 你們覺得沒意義
我以後少講這種東西好了
其實這才是有意義
怎麼會沒意義呢 我也不太懂
這一段喔 你看喔 3年前喔
我都說了有機會17000
17000以上有沒有看到 3年前喔
那時候才15000而已
為什麼我們行情高 而且AI的那個
AI的成長是指數型的成長
一般是線性型的這樣成長
來看我接下來講的話
拐點出現
本來是這樣子
變成這樣子喔
看一下喔
本來這樣子 變這樣子
你看我的手勢喔
他指數型是這樣子 90度的成長
不覺得很恐怖嗎
現在就是90度 不然呢
什麼叫90度
就是時間停留在這邊
它可以一直發展
AI可以一直發展AI
拐點快到了 拐點快到
所以不論對或錯
拐點快到 兩三年時間
這個拐點算很快
應該只有我算那麼快喔
不論對或錯一切的一切預告在前面
這一段你們覺得還好嗎
我投個票喔
你不要順著我的意思 我想知道
你真的覺得郭哲榮這沒什麼
也很多人講
最好是很多人講啦 好不好
你沒關係啦 你覺得你的想法
因為我想知道
講實在話
有時候也要講你們要聽的話
你們覺得這種預告
你們覺得沒什麼意義
我以後少講
我講給別人聽就好 我是認真的
我沒有噹你們啦 我想知道
這段預告你覺得重不重要
有沒有覺得很神奇
覺得很重要 很神奇的就回答
不重要 不神奇的
助理你就問他
剛才這段重播很重要 很神奇
不重要 不神奇
兩個選項讓他們選一下
來 我們來告訴你
所以3年10萬點
3年前15000
什麼下個月16000
太簡單了 我再跟你講
他們就是這一句話讓我更確定
3年內10萬點好不好
他們這一句話
讓我更確定3年內10萬點
但是我不會說百分之百
我是合格分析師 OK嗎
我是合格分析師 OK 來
來看一下
我又不是網紅
又不考執照 然後還要收費
又不受監管
來 智原 ASIC題材
他們還會去研發ASIC
特用晶片
很多公司都要投資AI
聽到這句話 我都想投資AI了
很多公司
不投資AI都被取代了
帆宣也拉起來了
今天上櫃指數怎麼樣 還在漲
今天上櫃指數還在漲
來 我們看一下
對 2023年跟你少講了
2023年我們看一下
助理給我圖
助理你2023年給我日線圖幹什麼
沒關係
2023年這時候15000有沒有看到
我那時候重播15000有沒有看到
後來漲到17000
現在多少
今天跌好慘喔
還有45000 三倍
3年後有沒有可能12萬點
有可能喔
我沒跟你開玩笑
3年後有沒有可能12萬點
只是3年後12萬點
我覺得賭太凶了
我就賭10萬點就好
賭10萬點我覺得機率蠻高的
OK 來
先來看大家投票
我記得沒錯ChatGPT
助理你幫我查一下
我記得ChatGPT
是2023年的時候
3月可能才有中文版
才是用到一般版本
給大部分人用或APP
助理你幫我
我不是請你幫我查一下嗎
有沒有都回答我一下喔
助理剛才指數性成長那個記得提醒我
我們來看一下
有啦 至少有8成啦
我想說大家覺得很無聊
8成OK
20%覺得無聊
20%不重要
20%你不覺得這個很厲害
這段3年前的90度重播有意義嗎
來 拉遠
那有啦 不覺得有意義的人
代表你根本看不懂
拜託那20%的人 我真的要講喔
你覺得沒有意義
要嘛就是你覺得比我優秀
我是覺得有點難啦
因為我最強項
比數學我算聰明
但是一定有人比我聰明
然後比記憶力 比考試
我算蠻會考的
但是一定一堆人比我會考
可是比預言能力 不好意思
我頂尖中的頂尖 好不好
如果你覺得這一段重播不重要
那要嘛就是你覺得還好
要嘛就是你覺得想要漲停板
那你應該去找漲停板的老師
不要找我
我是認真的 好不好
2023年5月嘛
5月才iOS APP嘛 沒錯啊
如果2023年5月31號
如果你問的是
台灣可不可以下載ChatGPT APP
而且可以講繁體中文
台灣在這一天開放iOS有沒有看到
是5月才開始
11月沒有啊
那小財飽這一句話
如果你問的是台灣何時可以下載
是2023年5月31號
小財飽我聽了就知道
你這是問AI對不對
哲哲如果我頭腦笨笨的
有辦法3萬滾到500萬嗎
你當問我這句話的時候
我覺得你已經在反思你自己了 很難啦
你要相信你自己好不好
笨笨的不是重點
你錢就去滾
就放在台灣50跟00662好不好
重點是 笨沒關係
重點是 我不是批評你 是你自己說的
笨沒關係 要認命
最怕的是笨又不認命
真的 我看很多人是這樣子
笨又不認命
又覺得很多事功勞都是他的
我看很多人失敗是這樣子
真的 笨沒有關係
你要知道自己的能力
我看過很多人 很有能力的人
又比他想像中更有能力
全世界大概只會出一兩位這種人
馬斯克啦
他有能力 但是他想像能力又比他更高
那是億中選一啊
大部分人不是
很多人失敗是這個原因
很笨 但是不認分
或是很聰明
那他又更不認分
他想的是更大的夢
我有看過有些分析師是這樣子
我說老實話 我也不要批評誰
我是說真的
或有些人 有些人員是這樣子
所以你有辦法3萬滾到500萬
有機會 但是你就是認命
股票不要太常進出 好不好
既然你都覺得笨了
太常進出 好不好
來 重點在了解自己沒有錯
笨要努力
對啊 你不能笨又不努力
我不是批評你笨喔
是有人問這個問題喔 OK嗎
我很笨 但是我很認命只買0050
我覺得很好啊
政大不是有一個很有名的教授
他就說他覺得
我記得沒錯是覺得他的操作還好
所以他買0050
我覺得他也幫助到很多人啊
當然最早講0050的是我
好不好 我們來看一下一些股票
來看一下 最後來看一下
所以今天上櫃指數
我記得沒錯是翻紅嘛 是不是
那個導播你可以幫我看嗎
沒關係 不用 我直接看
我現在不敢用期貨的畫面 氣死了
不敢用那個大盤畫面
對 明天那個
像今天是走勢圖
期貨是有點
這樣子上上下下
明天是有機會一路漲或一路跌喔
今天不算當沖順勢盤
當沖順勢盤是要嘛一路漲
來看一下喔 來
剩下8分鐘快點分析股票
好啦 雖然你今天這樣嗆我
今天的確有點不務正業
我告訴你
就是今天AI毀滅人類這個新聞
是讓我更興奮
我更加 我心中更加確定
3年內10萬點的機率非常高
我不會說百分之百
但是我會說非常 非常高
比3年前我跟你講
那90度的成長還更加確定
你要記得我這句話好不好
一定要記得我這句話
我不只是分析師
我喜歡當預言家
當分析師找別的分析師
每天要漲停板找別的老師
之前 玉晶光強講玉晶光
然後呢
永遠是啦 CPO強講CPO啦
都這樣啦
我沒有講誰
我完全知道手法就這樣子而已
就是這麼無聊
只要漲停板都是他家的
哪有這樣做股票
分析師做成這樣子
20年前的伎倆
我覺得太無聊了
我喜歡當預言家
我喜歡看很多人講一講
我自己講一講 我起雞皮疙瘩
我是認真的
2327國巨
人家村田製作所都已經要減產了
國巨怕什麼
不用怕啦
600元以下的國巨我跟你講
好好用力做多 好不好
真的你相信我好不好
環球晶也是一樣
這1000塊以下在想什麼東西
助理明天提醒我
我看有些人帶他去買環球晶好了
老天爺送給你禮物
大家現在就AI嘛 沒關係
有AI
AI大家怕泡沫
一會怕AI泡沫 沒辦法變現
就是AI沒辦法收錢
沒辦法轉換成錢
那一會又怕AI可以毀滅人類
AI可以毀滅人類
代表AI進步很多
那怎麼會沒辦法變現
AI能毀滅人類代表AI可以
什麼叫AI可以毀滅人類
AI能毀滅人類代表
AI有人類的思想
他們可以群體思想
而且他們有機器人 沒錯吧
他們可以生產出機器人
如果不能生產機器人
我們大部分把電腦給炸掉
網路給炸掉 他們能幹嘛
是不是
不是 他還可以自己生產機器人
他自己生產水跟電 沒錯吧
這叫AI毀滅人類
好 一會說AI
導播你不要在我前面轉
一會說AI很難變現
一會說AI可以毀滅全人類
AI毀滅全人類是
已經比人類高幾百萬等級了
那AI能毀滅人類的時候
代表AI早就可以取代所有人了
那可以取代所有人還不能變現嗎
所謂的變現就是
我可以做很多機器人
可以讓大家生活很好
我投資100萬可以賺1000萬的投資
然後我可以取代很多人類 是不是
全球是幾百兆的人類就業市場
一年幾百兆就業市場
你們付的薪水
老闆都把他省掉了
用機器人 用網路 用AI
一會說不可能
一會說馬上AI毀滅人類
你要信哪一個
現在看起來他們三個人講這樣的話
代表是有可能
那只代表一件事
AI進步很多
那不是更加確定3年10萬點
所以你不要跟我講那些東西
我在跟你談大海
你在跟我談漱口杯
沒關係 韓國瑜現在沒選舉
不然你們會覺得我支持誰
我都有支持
下一步那個救護車
我這次捐北部
下一次我要捐南部
好不好 OK
一定捐南部 好不好
明年就會6萬了 你到時候看到
我就是愛台灣 好不好
來 鴻海今天還不是拉起來是不是
對 上櫃指數還沒有講是不是
來 ChatGPT在中文圈爆紅
是1月底 2月初
在中文圈 是啊
因為之前還沒有人討論 是不是
你看我2 3月的時候
就那個影片 是不是
一個多月時間在講
好 不用投票了
那華邦電 記憶體也是一樣嘛
哲哲怎麼看記憶體
不要想太多 好不好
這個拉回來都可以買啦 好不好
記憶體沒大家想那麼差 好不好
但是我覺得記憶體
你也不要再加碼了
我覺得被動元件可以加碼到50%
記憶體頂多三成就好
助理你看一下
有沒有人買華邦電
買群聯的要注意一下 好不好
記憶體大概三成就好了
因為今天這個跌法不對
好不好 不對
當然我覺得營收
就是我怕的是本益比給他更低
那些外資分析師都看不懂股市
能怎麼辦
可是有時候長期而言還是會影響
繞來繞去 我覺得沒有那麼慘
一會說AI泡沫
一會說AI毀滅人類
毀滅人類代表可以取代所有人類
代表你的投資有價值
至少在還沒毀滅人類之前
投資有價值
所以代表什麼
AI真的會變現
AI可能毀滅人類
10%有可能毀滅人類的消息
傳出來代表的是
AI投資很恐怖
很快就可以賺到錢了
你要記得我這句話
他們現在不會讓超級無敵AI出現
至少會把現在超級AI
就是已經到80等級的AI
從低等級到80等級的AI
會好好的橫向發展
讓你跟這些AI串接起來
讓所有公司都可以用AI
他可不可以著力在這一塊
現在已經在做了 開放API
你懂我在說什麼
可能就佩服我在講什麼
今天講這些毀滅人類只是更確定
台灣股市要噴出去
記得我的邏輯
助理到時候寫文章要寫這個
3376新日興
我禮拜五會買那個
什麼勃根地紅
會拿出來給大家
也會買摺疊機
給大家看一下
我看一下好不好用 好不好
這個跟大家講
摺疊機有些人說滿漂亮的
我再看一下 來
然後再請助理
幫我買摺疊機的殼
我已經在想10月的事情了
精材怎麼看
精材就是漲太多了
哲哲你不是說要一直漲
可是我有沒有說過不要追
我一定有說不要追
現在股票真的追很痛苦
你有沒有發現到
一追就大跌 所以不要追
真的不要追 真的只能這樣
8299群聯怎麼看
從頭到尾就沒什麼漲
今天給我跌什麼東西
不用擔心
這邊離破底都有一段距離
好不好 OK嗎
我覺得記憶體拉回來還是可以買
OK嗎 南亞科也是一樣
我那時候就說了
這個大戶的手法就是慢慢創新高
再給你殺下去
有機會再給你拉起來
因為他持股的成分滿多的
持股的股數滿多的
裡面持股的大戶滿有名的
至少如果他是金居的做法的話
他會一直創新高
但是我現在講出來
我不知道他會不會就不用這樣的做法
人家是聰明人 來
然後還有3376新日興 來看一下
新日興怎麼看 哲哲怎麼看
就是這樣利多實現的時候Byebye
沒有那麼慘
只是AI股都沒漲 摺疊機算什麼
而且還有良率問題
所以我覺得新日興就先不要買
要買就買拉回的AI股
今天的股票真的沒什麼好講的好不好
5347世界先進又拉起來
其實我覺得沒什麼好講
就是你要謝謝
一堆股票 現在台灣股市45000
一堆股票大概41000 42000附近
國巨差不多4萬點附近而已
是不是
所以你要很開心
今天講到AI毀滅人類 我再強調一次
我講10次都可以
代表是AI進步很快
既然AI進步很快
你怎麼會講到
怎麼會有AI泡沫這件事
AI毀滅人類跟AI泡沫不一樣
AI泡沫是說我投資沒辦法收到錢
不會喔 AI已經進展到
可以做各式各樣的事情了
怎麼會收不到錢
AI的發明就是要讓大家過更好的人生
看起來有機會
只要不要毀滅人類
就是你們還在
就是現在的等級是80級
1到80級
你們還在討論
沒關係 導播
你們還在討論說
它有沒有只有40級的功用
其實大家已經討論
它是100級 200級的功用了
200等級的功用
所以講AI沒變現的人
他在討論很低階 低等的那種討論
你去想想看我的邏輯對不對
我是預言家
去想想看3年前講這些東西
我說拐點到了 90度了
你們看了不會起雞皮疙瘩
他那個90度的發展
我說90度發展代表什麼意思
為什麼他們很緊張
為什麼現在
奇怪 為什麼他們現在看到什麼東西
因為他們發現到
接下來這個拐點到了
AI會發明AI
一群AI一起用
因為他已經有AGI
他可以從無到有
那如果一群AGI的程式呢
AlphaGo以前就是這樣子
我早就知道 為什麼知道
以前看AlphaGo就知道
第一代贏了那個棋王以後
韓國棋王以後 世界棋王以後
他第二代到第三代
我說都不到一個月
你有沒有記得我一直跟你講
我說下一代
我有跟你講這個邏輯 你看
我說間距越來越快了
以前要半年一個版本
現在變一個月 以後變一天
我有沒有這樣講 有啦
所以說AI毀滅人類會很快
他們的意思是這個意思 這樣懂不懂
我是跟你講
我再講一個大事情
小事情就基本上都會上10萬點
你們趕快用力買好不好 真的啦
你們這3年不用力買
我覺得你們真的
你們3年後 你會覺得氣死
跟著哲哲17000
喊AI喊到10萬點
足足6 7倍
你來個6 7倍
那是說可能台灣50而已
可能1500萬就變一億了
6 7倍如果狠一點
你說有些股票可不可以2 30倍
當然有機會啊
所以你去想想看
或者一直換股票
你去想想看
我們今年很多股票都是翻倍的
去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
想清楚 想明白
今天股票真的都不用擔心
拉回用力買
嚇到大家了 對不起
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
我們專案已經結束了
可是你要趕快來
最好的專案是股票的優惠
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢